>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
AS AMERICAN FORCES WERE PULLING
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN THIS SUMMER,
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEF
OF THE JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF
ANNOUNCED A NEW AND HIGHLY
INNOVATIVE INTELLIGENCE
PARTNERSHIP.
THE PENTAGON HE EXPLAINED WOULD
BEGIN SHARING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION WITH THE TALIBAN.
YES, THE TALIBAN.
THE BEARD IS REALLY JUST
EXTREMIST AND ME IN PAJAMAS THA
FOR 23 YEARS HAVE WE HAVE BEEN
TOLD A MAJOR THREAT TO US IN TH
UNITED STATES.
BUT NO LONGER, THEY ARE OUR
PARTNERS NOW.
THE BIDEN MINISTRATION EXPLAINE
AND EVEN OPEN TO COORDINATING
WITH THE TALIBAN ON
COUNTERTERRORISM STRIKES AGAINS
OUR NEW ENEMY, A SHADOWY GROUP
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT ACTUALLY
EXIST CALLED ISIS K.
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FUTUR
OF THE TALIBAN'S.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU FROM PERSONA
EXPERIENCE, THAT THIS IS A
RUTHLESS GROUP FROM THE PAST.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY CHANGE
REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
AS FAR AS OUR DEALINGS WITH THE
AT THAT AIRFIELD OR IN THE PAST
YEAR OR SO IN THE WAR, YOU DO
WHAT YOU MUST.
IN ORDER TO REDUCE RISK TO
MISSION AND FORCE, NOT WHAT YOU
NECESSARILY WANT TO DO.
>> ANY THOUGHTS OF COORDINATION
WITH ISIS K?
>> IT'S POSSIBLE.
>> BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE FIGHTING
ISIS K, NO HOLDS ARE BARRED.
THE FIRST OF HIS CHLORINATED
ATTACKS AGAINST ISIS K ARRIVED
THREE WEEKS AGO, IT WAS AUGUST
29TH.
THAT WAS DAYS AFTER 13 AMERICAN
SERVICEMEN WERE KILLED IN A
BOMBING AT THE KABUL AIRPORT.
AT THE TIME EVEN DEMOCRATS ARE
POINTING OUT THE OBVIOUS, JOE
BIDEN IS SENILE AND TOTALLY
INCOMPETENT.
THE MINISTRATION AT THAT MOMENT
DESPERATELY NEEDED SOMETHING TO
PROVE THEY ARE NOT SENILE AND
INCOMPETENT, THEY ARE INSTEAD
DECISIVE AND STRONG.
WHAT BETTER WAY TO DO THAT THAN
TO KILL PEOPLE.
THEY BOMBED A WHITE TOYOTA IN A
RESIDENTIAL COMPLEX NOT FAR FRO
THE KUMBLE AIRPORT.
THE WHITE HOUSE TIDED THAT
STRIKE IS OVER THE HORIZON.
>> HE STRONGLY AGREED THAT THIS
WAS A GOOD THING.
>> AT THIS POINT, WE THINK THE
PROCEDURES WERE CORRECTLY
FOLLOWED.
AND IT WAS A RIGHTEOUS STRIKE.
>> EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON AGREED
.
ONE UNNAMED U.S. DEFENSE
OFFICIAL DESCRIBED IT TO
JENNIFER GRIFFIN THIS WAY QUOTE
COME UP MULTIPLE SUICIDE BOMBER
STRUCK BY U.S. DRONES TODAY IN
KABUL.
SIGNIFICANT EXPLOSIVES IN THE
AREA LED TO SECOND EXPLOSIONS.
THEY BEL